hello everyone as Jeff described earlier
we've come a long way since the days of
skip or even Auto skip think about
managing the supply chain in the context
of Amazon a global company that operates
in more than 80 185 different countries
across the globe our customers perhaps
many of you don't know or even want to
know how the right products ended up in
the right place for them before they
click the Buy button this means that our
systems our AI systems are hard at work
well in advance of any customer order
our forecasting systems have to predict
the appropriate amount of demand for
each product that we sell worldwide our
buying systems must determine how much
product to purchase and from which
suppliers and our suppliers range from
tiny mom-and-pops operating out of their
garages to large manufacturers and brand
owners our placement systems have to
figure out where to put the product so
it's as close to our customers as
possible and finally we have to produce
an accurate delivery promise so our
promise systems are also hard at work
managing this complexity becomes
increasingly more difficult when you
think about the context of Amazon when
we have prime where we offer one-day
delivery in some cases or in the cities
where we're operating prime now where
that delivery promise is an hour or less
this is what makes AI an absolutely
indispensable tool for us alright let's
take a couple of product examples it
would be my job would be relatively easy
to forecast demands to produce a single
day promise on products whose demand is
very predictable or you can imagine
linear take laundry soap trash bags
crackers things that people buy all the
time household items or even highly
seasoned even seasonal products like
wool socks in winter or sunscreen and
summer we know enough about those demand
patterns to be able to put those
products in the right warehouses close
to customers
make that one day promise unfortunately
forecasting is not that simple for all
products consider some of the variables
involved in weather we stock an item and
we're to have that product in inventory
we have to account for price elasticity
take the case of TV's a product that's
highly sensitive to price variations we
also need to be able to differentiate
between slow-moving products that some
customers want sometimes and products
that just won't sell it all take this
pickle flavored lip balm this may shock
you all but it is not a top seller and
we need to disaggregate disaggregate the
national demand to regional we have to
forecast for over 10,000 ZIP codes
across up to a dozen different delivery
options now we're going to talk about
two of our hardest challenges that we
face in forecasting those are predicting
demand for new products and estimating
demand for highly seasonal products like
Halloween costumes you never know which
products are gonna spike because of
happenings in popular culture
imagine if the latest season of Game of
Thrones would have just launched before
Halloween the increased demand we would
have seen for Game of Thrones costumes
this is actually why we started
deploying AI and machine learning and
our forecasting systems back in 2007 it
was to tackle these two very difficult
problems the development of our first
machine learning model which was called
sparse quantile random forests or
squirel for short represented a
significant innovation for forecasting
we based it as the name implies on the
popular random forest algorithm that
enables decision trees but we were able
to make this algorithm scale to billions
of training examples we were also able
to handle sparse data with missing input
values that allowed our forecasting
systems to consume information from
product descriptions and titles that had
previously been inaccessible the final
thing is we were able to get a full
probability distribution we don't
produce one forecasts we produce a
distribution of out
and square fin abled us to produce that
distribution for any point in time along
the year-long forecasting horizon so
squirt was very useful in exploiting
similarities with training samples using
text-based data but it wasn't able to
borrow the statistical strength of other
products across the time series
therefore we evolved our models and we
started to use deep learning from or
neural networks we began deploying deep
learning networks in our forecasting in
2015 and since then we've seen a step
change in accuracy the year we deployed
deep learning we saw a 15 times
improvement than we'd ever seen in
previous years this forecasting accuracy
translates to our customers in terms of
higher availability of the products they
want faster shipping speeds and
ultimately what we all want is lower
costs in 2016 we built a feed-forward
neural network or fnn model with F&N we
were able to predict distributions for
millions of products by outputting
quantiles across multiple forecasts
start dates and planning periods for
combinations up to a year ahead again
F&N was very successful but it also had
its limitations F&N required months of
manual training in other words for every
new use case or every new country that
we deployed we actually had to spend
months of our scientist time developing
the models training the models before we
could put the new model into production
to benefit our customers so as we do at
Amazon we evolved to newer and better
models our current models the newest
models are built around convolutional
neural networks they have automated
feature engineering which reduces a
manual effort and they access historical
demand directly which enables us to
learn across products for example long
history products we can learn for new
products and vice versa a practical
example of this is take digital cameras
they're constantly coming new to the
market
when a new digital camera comes to
market we can use the demand history
from the previous version to forecast
for the new product so this sounds great
we have models that learn on their own
and and produce accurate forecasts
however these while we've while we've
been building these automated and fully
trained models our teams actually
tripled in size because we need more
smart scientists to build the next
evolution of forecasting models we're
still hiring by the way so feel free to
send me a resume our work here is far
from done we know that deep learning in
its current state in our forecasting
systems has several limitations that our
previous systems didn't the first and
most obvious is these black box models
are far less explainable than models
that we had previously
this means that small changes in inputs
can generate large changes in outputs
that we can't fully explain so to solve
for this we've invented some human
levers so humans can provide inputs to
our forecasting models take an example
of a new book it's written by a
celebrity or a well-known author that
author often goes to social media or
talk shows to discuss and advertise for
the book our models couldn't possibly
know that there's a media blitz
surrounding the new release that might
drive demand so this is where our that
humans can provide inputs to our models
so that when this popular new book
releases its available for our customers
on the day of release ok so what's it
all mean my team forecasts for over 400
million products every single day for
worldwide customers it's clearly
impossible for a person or even a team
of people to create new unique forecasts
for each of these these items so for
niche products like this Nicolas Cage
magic reversible
sequined pillow cover if we had to do
forecasting manually we probably
wouldn't spend much time forecasting for
for Nick Cage but a neural network
that's trained on the appropriate loss
function can access thousands of other
products that are similar to this one
and produce a reasonable enough forecast
so that we can be sure that if one of
our customers in Las Vegas clicks buy
there's a good chance we can have it on
our doorstep within two days so I think
you can see that on the logistical
challenges we take on on a daily basis
ai is an absolutely critical tool for us
and we couldn't do it without it so now
that I've explained the science behind
forecasting we'll show a short video to
see how we use AI in our fulfillment
centers most people look at an amazon
fulfillment center and imagine all the
stuff inside when I look at it I see
data I'm Russell Al Gore chief scientist
with Amazon worldwide operations there
are 1 to 4 million bins per fulfillment
center and on the order of 10 million
items we have computer vision systems
analyzing images to help us securely
keep track of where everything is since
our fulfillment centers are set up
largely on a manhattan-style grid the
paths if the pods can follow is
relatively structured and organized so
the first decision I have to make is
which orders I want to pick at the same
time in order to get the items in the
same box and that's a large
combinatorial optimization problem that
I have to solve and I'm solving in
real-time using that information we try
to minimize the distance the pods have
to travel
we have decision engines and decision
logic AI optimization that's running to
make those decisions in real time on a
constant basis as the information
underneath the changes we may build
predictions of an action of how likely
am I to need to access this pod in the
next hour two hours three hours four
hours once we put a label on the box the
transportation execution systems and
processes all have to take over so we'll
use machine learning to build
information about how long it takes to
travel from point A to point B
to make the magic happen and get prime
shipping in one day we need to better
use all of that information which
machine learning and optimization at
scale enables us to do
[Music]